Guten Morgen, Thomas. Ich hoffe, du hast deine äh Datenschäfchen alle äh in einen sicheren Hafen reinfahren können.
Ich glaube nicht an sichere Efen.
Logbuchnetzpolitik, Ausgabe Nummer einhundertfünfundfünfzig und äh heute machen wir mal ein kleines äh Spezial, was nicht nur damit zu tun hat, dass äh Linus gerade mal,
verfügbar ist für diese Sendung und ich von daher mal hier äh ausnahmsweise mal den Hut aufhabe,
sondern auch weil wir ähm ja heute mal wieder mal äh ein bisschen die Perspektive nach Österreich äh richten wollen und das sogar aus
zwei Gründen.
Nämlich einerseits, weil äh es ohnehin von Zeit zu Zeit mal angemessen ist, da den Fokus drauf zu richten und andererseits, weil ja natürlich auch gerade sehr viel äh Wind äh erzeugt wird
Wegen dieser Österreicher, die so viel Ärger machen. Thomas, ich begrüße dich erstmal hier.
Zur Co-Moderation bisher den Hörern eigentlich wunderbar bekannt und schon oft auch hier gewesen.
Ähm und ja, wir können dann eigentlich auch gleich mal zu äh Thema Nummer eins äh voranschreiten ohne viel ähm Teil zu vergeuden.
Und dabei begrüßen wir dann nämlich auch gleich noch den äh weiteren Gast, den wir hier noch mit in der Leitung haben. Ich sage hallo zu zu Max, Max Shemps, hallo.
Genau, du bist ja auch aus Österreich, deswegen äh konnte ich mir gerade den Witz nicht verkneifen.
Ähm ja, worum geht's? Äh ganz klar. Äh wir wollen natürlich reden über das äh Urteil,
des Europäischen Gerichtshof, was äh gestern so ein bisschen eingeschlagen hat wie eine Bomber, habe ich zu den Eindruck, weltweit.
Ähm zu ja ausgelöst durch eigentlich deine versus Facebook-Kampagne, die wir ja hier auch schon einige Male angesprochen haben und wir haben auch hier in der letzten äh Sendung im Prinzip ja auch schon,
besprochen, dass es äh absehbar war, wie das Urteil des Europäischen Gerichtshofs ausgeht.
Weil ja der Generalanwalt der EU-Generalanwalt im Prinzip das alles schon so äh beschrieben hat und erfahrungsgemäß und so war's halt auch diesmal wieder hat sich das Gericht eigentlich der Meinung dieses Generalanwalts äh weitgehend angeschlossen
Ja, du hast das ja jetzt im Prinzip alles ausgelöst und ich wollte mal so ein bisschen die Gelegenheit nutzen, mit dir zu sprechen, auch um einfach nochmal nachzuzeichnen.
Wie es eigentlich dazu kam, wann äh wann hast du eigentlich damit angefangen mit der ganzen.
Michael die USA eben studiert und ähm das war im Silicon Valley und das war ganz nett, weil Juristen sozusagen, die nicht gewusst haben, dass da ein Europäer im Raum sitzt.
Und die Grundaussage war so, ja, die Europäer mit ihrem Datenschutz sind eh ganz süß, aber kannst du machen, was du willst.
Als US-Unternehmen in Europa passiert eh nichts. Und das war so ein bisschen die Idee mal Facebook in dem Fall als ein Unternehmen genauer anzuschauen. Also mir ist ja Facebook jetzt vergleichsweise Wurst. Es gibt ja zehn andere Unternehmen oder weiß nicht wie viele die andere ähnliche Dinge machen,
die Idee sozusagen ein Unternehmen genau mal anzuschauen, damit man eben nicht so Verschwörungstheoretisch nach dem Motto, die machen ja alle irgendwelche bösen Dinge,
unterwegs ist und ähm das Spannende ist, dass die aus Steuergründen alle in Luxemburg und Irland sitzen, also Facebook ist zu zweiundachtzig Prozent äh in Irland,
Und damit hat man die eigentlich unter europäischen Recht und damit kann man auch durchaus dann spielen. Und das ist jetzt gerade in dem Fall recht spannend, weil die ja,
Unterschied zwischen europäischen Recht und US-Recht zum Beispiel Steuerfragen zu nutzen, damit sie am Ende fast keine Steuern zahlen nutzen, sie halt den Unterschied da.
Sind nicht bei der ganzen Datenschutz und Überwachungsthematik, zerreißt das ein bisschen die die Konzerne, weil die nach europäischem Recht diese Dinge eigentlich nicht tun dürften. Und nach US-Recht müssen sie aber und das ist dann eigentlich so die Ausgangslage gewesen, was ganz spannend war,
Problem ist, dass in Irland die Datenschutzbehörde für europaweit zuständig ist und wie eh schon bekannt, sind die sehr beflissen dabei, jeden Grund zu finden, nichts zu tun.
Und ähm dementsprechend auch.
Ist da auch nicht wahnsinnig viel rauskommen und die Überlegung war dann eben aus Irland rauszugehen und in Österreich haben wir dort noch eine Sammelklage entsprechend gemacht, die praktisch die irischen Sachen sind.
Das war jetzt zwanzig äh zwanzig dreizehn, ne? Hast du damit angefangen?
Anfangen hat es zweitausendelf, das war die erste Runde sozusagen, das waren in Irland, das hat mir nicht mehr so hochgespiegelt als die zweiundzwanzig Beschwerden, als ob das eine ganze Lawine gewesen wäre. In Wirklichkeit war sozusagen jeder Button eine Beschwerde. Man hätte das Ganze auch in einen Dinger einschreiben können,
drei Jahre lang dahin gegangen und die irische Behörde gibt einem da dann keine Akteneinsicht, man darf von seinem eigenen Verfahren nichts wissen, wenn man Anträge stellt, kriegt's einfach eine E-Mail zurück, wo steht, interessiert uns nicht,
Also ähm ich habe dann irgendwann einmal das beschreibt vielleicht die Sache am besten mit dem zuständigen Datenschutz damals gesprochen und habe gesagt, naja, es gibt ja in Europa so Grundrechte auf ein faires Verfahren und so,
wo ich doch die Akten in meinem Verfahren sehen darf und doch auch was sagen darf in meinem Verfahren. Und die Antwort war, nö, Artikel sechs, europäische Menschenrechtskonvention, wo das drinnen steht, gilt für unsere Behörde nicht.
Dann die Behörde fragst, warum, dann sagt die Behörde, das sagen wir denen nicht warum. Und du stehst da an,
Ähm ich habe dann der der alte Commission ist in Pension gegangen. Ich wollte ihn kurz zur Pensionierung dann irgendwie KFK der Prozess mal schicken,
es wäre gut angebracht. Leider war er dann bei der Verhandlung nicht dort, deswegen hat sich das dann irgendwie nicht ergeben. Aber ähm der Vizekommission, der zuständig ist für die Sache ist jetzt der Chief Privacy Officer von Apple ihr Land, ähm weil Apple halt auch seinen Sitz dort hat.
Es stinkt dort einfach wirklich zum Himmel, was da abgeht,
Ähm und deswegen war ein bisschen die Überlegung mit den ganzen Sachen nach Österreich zu ziehen in Form einer Sammelklage, weil das einfach vergebene Liebesmühe in Irland gewesen wäre. Man kann natürlich davor die Gerichte ziehen, aber,
bin ich dann ein Opa, bis man da irgendwann mal sein erstes Akt ein Ding herausbekommt, weil wenn sich eine Behörde halt wirklich auf dem Bauch liegt und sagt,
ignorieren das vollkommen, dann kommt nix für raus. Das Spannende jetzt für die EUGH-Sache war, ähm dass die irgendein dieser Beschwerde zu Prison und Überwachung überhaupt gleich ganz nicht mal bearbeitet haben,
sofort rausgeschmissen, haben gesagt, dass sie frisol ist, weil die Rechtsmeinung, die ich vertrete, eine acht absolut frivole Rechtsmeinung ist, die sozusagen keine Möglichkeit hat, jemals fürs fürs für wahrgenommen zu werden.
Moment ist das ein Fachbegriff, Rechtsmeinung.
Das Geile dran ist, dass dadurch das so eine heiße Kartoffeleffekt gehabt hat. Also die irische Hürde wollte diese ganze Maßüberwachung überhaupt nicht machen, sofort heiße Kartoffel weg,
dann ist das vor einem irischen gelandet. Der Richter hat an sich politisch gut entschieden, aber rechtlich teilweise ein bisschen fragwürdig,
hat die heiße Kartoffel damit sofort zum EuGH geschossen und damit bist du mit dieser Mastüberwachungsthematik in kürzester Zeit auf einmal vorm höchsten Gericht in Europa gelandet. Und das war eigentlich ganz schön, weil,
der Fall halt so ein klassisches Schnellweg damit und damit sozusagen sofort durch die Instanzen hinauf marschiert ist,
und das war eigentlich jetzt relativ spannend. Ähm jo und damit ist dann dieses Urteil gestern da der Herberg gekommen.
Das ist ja interessant, die Männer haben sich ja im Prinzip ins eigene äh Fleisch äh geschnitten in gewisser Hinsicht.
Also
sozusagen nur weg, nur weg ähm und dann ist halt irgendwann einmal dort, wo es gelandet ist, dann noch geschissener gewesen ist, wie wenn man was zu essen sozusagen einfach äh fünf Jahre lang einen Nonsensverfahren geführt hat, was so die Alternative gewesen wäre
Grundsatzproblem ist halt, dass wir diese unabhängigen Datenschutzbehörden haben und diese Unabhängigkeit zwanzig sich immer ganz toll anhört,
Wir haben eben in einigen Staaten das Phänomen, dass die Politik halt jemanden hinsetzt, der da unabhängig acht Jahre lang nichts tut.
Und die Politik stellt sich hin und sagt, ja wir haben ja kein Waisungsrecht, diesen unabhängigen Behörden gegenüber, also können wir ja nichts.
Und ähm das ist so ein bisschen das Ich, was wir haben, dass wir da beim Grundrechtsdurchsetzung durchaus ähm Probleme haben, wenn die Behörde halt einfach nicht will.
Ähm weil die auch nicht politisch verantwortlich ist in dem Sinne, weil eben nicht weisungsgebunden
Das heißt, ich kann da nur vor Gericht ziehen und diese Behörden verklagen, dass sie ihren Job tun und das ist, macht natürlich kein Normalbürger, ähm und das ist ein bisschen spannend bei der ganzen Kiste.
Hast du denn ähm was hier ist eigentlich der alleinige Klageführer oder hast du dich jetzt beim EuGH auch noch mit anderen Gruppen zusammengetan, irgendeiner Form?
Das war eigentlich allein gemacht, was auch immer irgendwie total strange, es war auf jedem Urteil, es bleibt dann oben drauf steht's selbst. Bin immer so, könnten wir das nicht fallen? Dreihundertzweiundsechzig Slash vierzehn nennen.
Ähm aber.
Das funktioniert halt auch gar nicht so schlecht. Also ich glaube, dass das ja auch ähm ganz angenehm war, eben Digital Rights Island, die auch diesen Forest Datenspeicherungskiste gemacht haben, die haben sich ja dann im allerletzten Moment auf einmal noch,
diesem Verfahren hinzufügen lassen als Freund des Gerichtes, was einen irgendwie interessanter Move war, weil wir jahrelang gesagt haben, na, sie können leider überhaupt nicht helfen und sie wissen auch überhaupt nicht, wo sie einen Anhalt in Irland gibt, der uns da helfen könnt.
Und kaum ist es dann zum gegangen, war anscheinend
groß genug, dass man da auf einmal sofort dabei sein wollte. Also das war auch irgendwie recht spannend, weil sonst ja das innerhalb der Datenschutz-NGOs ich es eigentlich immer recht gut funktioniert, aber das war immer so ein bisschen ein strange Situation dort.
Ist jetzt auch nicht so, dass du keine Unterstützung äh erhalten hättest auf dem Weg dahin.
Nein, also das Ganze ist sozusagen im Prinzip finanziert über eine Crowdfunding Seite, die sozusagen jetzt Thema selber programmiert, hauptsächlich mit dem Hintergrund, dass wir gesagt haben, naja, wir brauchen eigentlich nur eine Versicherung, weil wenn ich gewinne, kriege ich meine Kosten eher selbst im Großen und Ganzen,
Ich verliere ist ja das Riesenproblem, gerade in Irland zahlt man da Anwaltskosten, die nicht hunderttausende Euro gehen,
ähm und das kann sich halt niemand leisten. Und deswegen haben wir das mit einer Crowdfundingartigen Geschichte gemacht,
wo die Leute das Geld spenden können. Wenn's aber dann am Ende nicht gebraucht wird, kann man's wieder rücküberweisen.
So eine Art Haftungscrowdfunding vor, also in die Richtung.
Das findet jetzt äh quasi auch statt.
Genau, das ähm wird also wir hatten natürlich noch aufs Endurteil in Irland, weil die Sache noch zurückgeht. Ähm es hat auch die Option gegeben, dass die Leute sagen können, wir spenden, es soll, also das Geld soll einfach gespendet werden,
und das haben auch die meisten gemacht. Also ich glaube so um die neunzig Prozent Spenden waren auch Spenden im Sinne von ich will das Geld gar nicht zurück. Natürlich war also die mehr gespendet haben ein paar hundert Euro haben dann öfters angeklickt bitte den Rest wieder Retour
auch noch lustige Arbeit, diese ganzen Sachen, wieder zurück dann zu überweisen.
Wie viel ist denn da zusammengekommen?
Jetzt sind wir so bei fünfundsechzigtausend Euro, was dann doch recht viel war. Ähm und ist eigentlich auch relativ schnell gegangen. Ich hab's nicht mehr weiter beworben, weil wir eigentlich gecovert waren dann.
Und das andere, was noch spannend war, ist in Irland haben wir das erste Mal einen.
Kostenlimitierung bekommen, also in Irland gibt's kein Gesetz, wo drinnen steht, wie viel am Ende, wer wen zahlen muss, also in Österreich gibt's da einfach ein Gesetz, wo drinnen steht, äh so viele Stunden, dieser Satz, was weiß ich, da weiß man sogar, was man zahlen muss auf der anderen Seite. In Irland sagt dann der letzte Richter in der Reihe, ja, so circa dreihunderttausend Euro, hört sich super an.
Ähm und da kann man da wirklich bankrott gehen. Ähm in Irland habe ich dann eben den Antrag gestellt, eine Kostenlimitierung vorab zu bekommen, was in Irland noch nie funktioniert hat,
und der Richter war aber so geil, das zum,
meiner Meinung nach, ähm dass der dann da zugestimmt hat, weil ich gesagt habe, ich ziehe sonst die Beschwerde zurück, weil ich bin ja nicht dämlich, dass ich mich da irgendwie ähm bis über drei Köpfe verschuld. Ähm.
Wobei ich im Hintergrund muss man sagen, ich habe mich dann auch beim Bundeskanzleramt in Österreich informiert, ob eigentlich so eine ähm verwaltungsrechtliche
in Österreich überhaupt durchsetzbar wären, das wäre ganz lustig gewesen, als wäre in Österreich gar nicht also durchsetzbar gewesen, also solange ich mir keins kein Sommerhaus in Irland dann irgendwann mal gekauft hätte, wäre es
sozusagen dann an der Durchsetzbarkeit gescheitert, aber man will jetzt auch nicht da vor Gericht gehen und sagen, bä, ihr kriegt das Geld nicht, weil sie's nicht durchsetzen könnt, sondern das.
Und ist es dann limitiert worden.
Genau, auf zehntausend Euro, also insofern sind wir ich Oberkörper. Ähm es hat ganz funktioniert.
Ähm gut, jetzt ist äh das Urteil äh vorgelegt worden,
Was steht denn da eigentlich genau drin? Was hat denn jetzt das EuGH ähm also was war denn überhaupt die Frage sozusagen? Also was was war denn sozusagen äh der Kerninhalt deiner deiner Klage und wie ist darauf reagiert worden?
Inhaltlich war der Kerninhalt wirklich dieser Safehaber-Regelung,
der irische Richter hat bloß bloß in die Frage nicht hineinformuliert, wenn man nach irischem Recht, dass da noch einer Stelle vorliegen müsste, wenn's eine Gültigkeitsfrage wäre,
und dementsprechend hat er das geschickt, umformuliert und die ganze Erklärung war, wenn das alles nicht gültig ist und so weiter und so fort, aber die, es ist doch nicht in der Frage drinnen gestanden, was dann einige so Business ähm,
Juristen ganz fertig gemacht hat, weil was entscheidet da eigentlich, was was gar nicht in der Frage drinnen steht, ob das Kernproblem war, eben diese Seefahrerregelung,
Seefahrer ist ja schon immer kritisiert worden, weil's einfach effektiv keinen Datenschutz bietet in der täglichen Praxis. Also was Unternehmen mit den Daten tun.
Das ist aber jetzt nicht Kern dieses Falls gewesen, der Fall war jetzt wirklich nur Massenüberwachung in den USA und der EUGH hat auch nur zu dem Punkt, was gesagt, wir haben natürlich zur allgemeinen,
Schutzniveau, was die Farbe mir täglich, wenn ich halt mit irgendwelchen Googles und sonst was meine Datenaustausch bietet, auch was gesagt aber erwartungsgemäß hat das Gericht halt diese Geschichte in diese Kiste ist nicht mehr reingesprungen,
ähm
und die Kernaussage ist eben CEVA bietet gegen diese Massenüberwachung keinen Schutz. Ähm diese Massenüberwachung betrifft sogar den Kernbereich des Grundrechts nach sieben und acht. Ähm der der Kater
und vor allem hab ich auch keine Rechtsdurchsetzung und auch da sagt der EuGH, dass eben der Bereich betroffen ist.
Und das ist extrem, weil, ich glaube, der Kernbereich, wir haben gesucht nach irgendeinem Fall, wo jemals schon gesagt worden ist, der Kernbereich ähm meines Rechts auf Datenschutz, es ist juristisch gesagt, sozusagen der Bereich, wo keine gültiges Gegenargument mehr gilt vor lauter Überwachung,
dass der's noch legitimieren kann. Also es gibt sozusagen den Bereich Kernbereich. Das ist,
ein Jurist hat das schön gesagt, off the scale, also einfach so jenseitige Überwachung, dass die nicht mehr irgendwie legitimiert werden kann.
Entschuldigung, du meinst jetzt äh Kernbereich der Privatsphäre oder Kernbereich.
Bereich des Grundrechts sozusagen. Das ist ähm zweiundfünfzig, glaube ich, von der Charter,
Es gibt eben den Kernbereich, da kann ich gar nicht eingreifen und dann gibt's sozusagen alles andere, da geht's dann um Verhältnismäßigkeit, also zum Beispiel bei der Vorratsdatenspeicherung ist gesagt worden, na ja, es sind ja nicht die Inhaltsdaten, deswegen ist es ja noch nicht unbedingt der Kernbereich, aber es ist unverhältnismäßig.
In dem Fall ist es wirklich der Kernbereich auch mal betroffen und ich habe zumindest nie einen Fall gefunden, wo das bisher schon argumentiert worden ist, also von dem her ist es halt auch relativ brown breaking. Und das andere, was mich auch noch wahnsinnig fasziniert, ist, dass es eben unter sieben und acht argumentiert worden ist und sieben von der Kater,
die es nur für EU Recht gilt,
bis acht um ähm von der aber auch für Überwachung europäischer Staaten gilt. Das heißt zum Beispiel die Fälle, die jetzt ähm PI in in in UK hochkriegt.
Privacy International.
Genau. Ähm.
Die ähm wir haben natürlich erst fröhlich nach Straßburg marschieren und sagen, ja aber Luxemburg hat doch gesagt, dass das schon sozusagen Masterüberwachung ist, die total illegal ist.
Kannst du das nochmal mit der Sieben oder Acht nochmal kurz äh äh aussortieren? Also was ist was meinst du mit sieben und acht?
Sieben von der Karte ist Privatsphäre, acht von der Karte ist das Grundrecht auf Datenschutz und acht von der, von der europäischen Menschenrechtskonvention ähm ist praktisch der Siebener von der.
Es sind sozusagen vier, drei Artikel sieben und acht ähm überlagern sich jeweils gegenseitig ähm in den verschiedenen Dingern.
Ist die Charter von der Mental Rides der Europäischen Union und das andere ist die europäische Menschenrechtskonvention und das sind zwei unterschiedliche Grundrechts äh Bausteine, die wir haben, die auch unterschiedliche Anwendungsbereiche haben. Weil das eine in der EU ist und das andere auch darüber hinaus.
Ist sozusagen die für die EU,
und die MHK ist ähm kein Teil der EU, ähm sondern vom Europarat und da ist äh das geht auch viel weiter. Das sind siebenundvierzig Länder, glaube ich, waren's dabei. Also das geht von Russland bis Türkei und was weiß ich.
Und das Spannende ist, die EU und damit die die ganze Grundrechte-Karte,
ist hat keinen Anwendungsbereich auf Security, weil das äh sozusagen nationalstaatlicher Bereich ist. Da hat die EU nichts zu husten,
aber eben diese MRK hat keine Ausnahme für eine asiat Security. Das heißt, da kann man's dann in Straßburg wieder und das ist dann politisch nicht unspannend, weil's einen gewissen Fall zwischen Luxemburg und Straßburg gerade geht, wer da bessere Grundrechtschätzer ist
Das heißt, da kann man dann durchaus hin und her laufen. Also wir haben das auch in unserer Submission geschrieben so nach dem Motto,
Wenn ihr uns das nicht gibt, dann müssen wir dann schon nach Straßburg gehen, ne? Und also das könnte auch nicht unspannend werden.
Also das Urteil hat also EMRK, äh müsst ihr mal müssen wir mal aufpassen, hier bei den schnellen Abkürzungen. Europäische Menschenrechts äh Konvention ist damit gemeint. Ähm das ist das eine, worauf sich ähm.
Dieses Urteil bezieht und und die Grundrechte.
Es bezieht sich auf die Charter, aber der Text in der EMRK ist eins zu eins gleich bei dem relevanten Ding. Das heißt, man wird das einfach Copy Basen können.
So, das heißt.
Wenn ich das richtig rauslese, hat diese Entscheidung schon ziemlich grundlegende Konsequenzen. Also das geht sozusagen eigentlich auch im Prinzip ist, ist das so in etwa das, was du erwartet hast oder ist das irgendwie mehr, als du erwartet hast?
Naja, eigentlich sozusagen vom von der Logik war das die logische Konsequenz. Das war auch die Überlegung von der ursprünglichen Beschwerde in Irland, dass man mal irgendwo reinsticht, wo man Juristdiktion hat. Das Grundproblem bei dieser ganzen Überwachungsdebatte ist halt, dass sich verschiedene Staaten ausrichten, dass sie unglücklich drüber sind, dass sie sich gegenseitig überwachen.
Big News, da kann man dann wettern, also nette Briefchen schreiben,
Ähm das Lustige ist aber dadurch, dass wir diese Privatisierung der Überwachung haben, dass wir halt Firmen haben, die die Daten erst sammeln und dann weitergeben, habe ich über die Firmen schon Juristik. Auch als Europa.
Und das ist sozusagen der der Punkt, wo man angreifen kann und wo man rum einstechen kann und sagen kann, na ja, bei den Firmen kann ich aber dann zumindest sagen, ihr dürft's da nicht mitspielen und ähm wenn sozusagen
X die Daten an und Government Y nicht weitergeben kann, dann bricht es zumindest ein Teilbereich dieser Überwachungskiste ein bisschen zusammen, ne?
Und ähm das andere ist, dass man da auch politisch ein gewisses Druckmittel gegenüber die USA hat, was natürlich nicht jetzt sozusagen,
diplomatisch die feine Art ist, aber die diplomatische Art hat jetzt die EU glaube ich zwei, drei Jahre lang probiert, mit praktischen null Konsequenzen,
und das ist ein bisschen so die Überlegung bei der ganzen Kiste, dass man eben sagen kann, na ja, wenn ihr tollen, äh praktisch unlimitierten Zugang zu unserem Markt haben wollt, dann hätten wir ganz gerne wenig Überwachung.
Und ich glaube, dass das ein ganz spannender äh Move ist, ähm wie man daraus machen kann. Das war so ursprünglich die Überlegung
Diese ganze Debatte nach Snowden war, wo halt alle sich riesig aufgeregt haben, aber einfach alles sinnlos war von diesen ganzen Aktionen. Und dachte, da kann man zumindest mal reinstochern und schauen, was passiert.
Ob das alles funktioniert werden wir natürlich erst sehen, aber es ist zumindest ein netter Tick heute, ne?
Ja, aber es ist, es ist ja jetzt, ich bin mir jetzt gerade nicht so sicher, ob bei der Entscheidung über die Vorratsdatenspeicherung, glaube ich, hat ja diese ganze Überwachungsgeschichte ähm nur so Peripher eine Rolle gespielt. Hier ist ja jetzt im Prinzip das erste Mal, dass äh die Snoaden League mehr oder weniger direkt
genannt werden, ne? Also nicht, weiß nicht, ob das Wort äh Snoten da.
Auch genannt.
Taucht, taucht auch explizit drin auf. Ist ja auch schon mal sehr interessant. Ähm.
Übrigens dort auch nochmal bestätigt sozusagen. Also wir haben jetzt schon mehrere Höchstgerichte, die gesagt haben, also das, was Noten sagt, das stimmt und das nehmen wir mit in unserer Begründungen auf.
Mhm. Na, das ist interessanter.
Die USA sagen ja noch immer es stimmt nicht, was ja total süß war in der Reaktion, wo die gesagt haben, wir haben nichts davon gewusst und wir wurden nicht gehört und überhaupt ist das ganz gemein, was da so von uns behauptet.
Was ja lustig ist, weil die USA von Anfang an genau gewusst haben, dass dieses Verfahren läuft,
Ähm das war überall in den Medien, äh das war auch ein Vertreter von der US-Botschaft, weil er während der Verhandlung dort, die haben auch die Tage,
Tag vor der Verhandlung noch äh praktisch alle Mitgliedsstaaten durchtelefoniert und da wahnsinnig interveniert, dass die was anderes zu argumentieren haben,
ähm äh also so diese von wegen wir haben ja nichts gewusst und da wurde hinter unserem Rücken was böse entschieden, ist ja auch total absurd, aber.
Äh das hatte ich auch noch gesehen äh äh sie meinten ja auch eine Zustimmung äh des äh EuGH, also jetzt sozusagen zu deiner Argumentation würde ja dem Schutz der Bürgerrechte und dem freien Fluss von Informationen großen Schaden zufügen.
Also es war total spannend gestern zu sehen, die einen haben gesagt, das Internet bricht auseinander, morgen mindestens. Und die anderen waren sozusagen, dass es vollkommen irrelevant
überhaupt kein Problem und so weiter. Es war ganz schön zu sehen, wie sozusagen je nachdem, aus welcher Position und was jemand argumentieren wollte, das gleiche Urteil irgendwie gar nichts bedeutet hat, also zum Beispiel Facebook und die EU-Kommission haben ja gesagt, sie sind total bestätigt worden
ähm und Facebook hat irgendwo anscheinend aus dem Urteil rausgelesen, dass er ausdrücklich drinnen steht, dass er sich an alle Gesetze gehalten haben. Ich habe das nirgendwo gefunden auf den Seiten
ähm
und gleichzeitig die Lobbyverbände, die jetzt in Brüssel gerade probieren, diese ganze Datenschutzreform möglich zu kicken, ähm haben natürlich sofort gesagt, dass das Ende des Internets und die ganze Regulierung ist böse und gemein und, und, und, und so weiter, ne.
Ja, das ist natürlich jetzt die Fragestellung, ne, also welche welche mittelfristigen und langfristigen Konsequenzen äh haben wir denn jetzt eigentlich zu
erwarten. Also vielleicht mal konkret, weil ja Facebook auch die ganze Zeit im Titel stand, auch wenn du wieder gesagt hast, dass jetzt nicht unbedingt die einzige Stoßrichtung ist, aber irgendwie ist es ja äh erstmal ein Kampf gegen Facebook äh auf den ersten Metern,
gibt es denn jetzt unmittelbare Konsequenzen? Also gut, du hast ja gesagt, das geht eh noch mal nach Irland und wir werden dann sehen, wie da im Detail nochmal.
Heute bestätigt worden am zwanzigsten Oktober, ist das in Irland der nächste Hering?
Okay, gut. Und und was genau muss da bestätigt werden durch Irland? Also was.
Ähm das äh sozusagen der EuGH kann ja nur Rechtsfragen machen und kann sozusagen faktisch nichts durchsetzen oder so. Das heißt ähm das irische Gericht muss dann die bindende Entscheidung ähm machen, die einfach diesem EuGH-Urteil folgen wird. Ähm.
Und haben die dann noch irgendwelche Freiräume, um das zu drehen?
Nicht wirklich. Also, ich glaube auch, dass die irische Richter nicht wahnsinnig das Bedürfnis hat, das zu drehen.
War zumindest mein Eindruck während der Verhandlung was natürlich sein kann ist dass jetzt nochmal weiter von den zu bringen weil die halt irgendeinen Einspruch dagegen erheben.
Den irischen Supreme Court.
Genau, ja, aber es ist halt.
In Wirklichkeit relativ wurscht, was in Ehrenamt passiert. Ähm weil das die irische Behörde das sowieso nie durchsetzen wird, das war von Anfang an klar, also es ist eher spannend sozusagen, dass jetzt achtundzwanzig Mitgliedsstaaten ähm im Einzelfall prüfen können und nicht mehr diese Seefahrerabkommen sie daran hindert,
und jetzt gehe ich mal davon aus, dass Weißgold Belgien, Deutschland, Frankreich und so weiter, vielleicht ein bisschen motivierter sind, was zu tun als wir jetzt die Iren oder die Luxemburger, ne?
Mhm. Und das heißt doch, dass die anderen Datenschutzbehörden jetzt auch wirklich äh tätig werden können gegenüber amerikanischen Firmen, um die Interessen ihrer Bürger durchzusetzen.
Genau, beziehungsweise jeder Bürger kann eine Beschwerde dorthin schicken. Ab heute und sagen, äh meine Daten, Hausnummer, meine Universität hat alle Daten in die Google Cloud ausgelagert und ich bin der Zwangsverpflichtet, dass meine Datenvolanden, wo die NSA wahrscheinlich Zugriff drauf hat,
das will ich nicht und eine Beschwerde macht und so weiter,
das Ding ist halt das Recht, hat sich jetzt drüber nachgeändert, also mich war nicht so happy, dass es keine Übergangsfrist gegeben hat dazu, weil es wäre für Unternehmen durchaus sinnvoller gewesen, wenn's zwei, drei Monate Übergangsfrist gegeben hätte, weil ganz ehrlich gesagt, jetzt haben wir das seit drei, vier Jahren, ob's da jetzt noch zwei, drei Monate Übergangsfrist gibt oder nicht, ist auch ein bissl Wurst.
Ähm das hat irgendwelchen Gründen nicht gemacht.
Aber es wird jetzt natürlich, es ist nicht so, dass die Unternehmen morgen den gezogen bekommen, weil Datenschutzverfahren dauern halbes Jahr bis Jahr, also da habe ich viel Zeit noch irgendwas zu tun und die Behörden sind jetzt auch nicht hyperaktiv bei so Sachen. Aber natürlich kann ich jetzt als Einzelbürger mich da auch drauf berufen et cetera.
Aber was ähm was erwartest du denn jetzt an an konkreten Auswirkungen? Erstmal für die US-Unternehmen, die jetzt unsere äh privaten Daten vorhalten.
Man muss sich's wirklich genau anschauen. Also es gibt im Gesetz zwei ähm Paragraphen. Der eine ist der Fünfundzwanziger, das andere ist der Sechsundzwanziger, ein fünfundzwanziger ist drinnen definiert, das sind Länder, wo alles sozusagen super ist, perfekter Datenschutz, da gibt's überhaupt keine Hindernisse, Daten hin und her zu schicken.
Äh du meinst jetzt, dass welches Gesetz, auf welches.
Datenschutzrichtlinie fünfundneunzig, sechsundvierzig, ähm.
Fünfundzwanziger Sitz der Fall zum Beispiel die Schweiz drunter. Die hat de facto das europäische Datenschutzrecht übernommen. Da macht's keinen Sinn, da jetzt irgendwo Grenzen aufzuziehen.
Außerhalb von Europa gibt's nur vier Länder, die diesen Status haben, das ist ähm Israel, ähm Kanada, Neuseeland und Argentinien,
alle anderen Ländern, vor allem unter sechsundzwanzig. Und Chaber war sozusagen fünfundzwanzig, das war so Privilegierung für Unternehmen in den USA,
jetzt weg und damit fallen diese Unternehmen unter den anderen Paragraphen den sechsundzwanziger. Ähm,
gibt's X Möglichkeiten, Daten zu transferieren. Ähm das fängt an, von deiner Zustimmung des Nutzers,
nicht so leicht ist in dem Fall, weil es muss eine informierte Zustimmung sein und diese Unternehmen dürfen ja auf der einen Seite nicht sagen, dass sie Massenüberwachung machen, nach US-Recht, gleichzeitig müssten sie erst europäische Nutzer darüber informieren, dass sie genau das tun,
was auch ein kleiner Limbo ist, also weil wir einige gesagt haben, wir machen einfach einen Paragrafen rein in unsere, in unsere Policy. Ja, viel Spaß dabei, weil jetzt informiert's mal die Leute, was ihr wirklich tut, ähm wo ihr ja eigentlich nach US Recht sie gar nicht informieren dürft.
Das wird durchaus glaube ich spannender, als sich einige denken,
Und es gibt aber andere Rechtsgrundlagen wie zum Beispiel die Erfüllung eines Vertrags, also typischer Fall, ich buche ein Hotel in New York, dann müssen meine Daten natürlich nach New York gehen, ich zahle mit einer Kreditkarte irgendwo,
und die Sachen liegen halt müssen halt dementsprechend dort sein, wirklich relevant wird's bei Auslagerung in Fällen. Also wenn ein Unternehmen in Europa,
ähm in die Cloud stellt,
wenn ich privat nutze auf jeden Fall nicht drunter, weil die ganze Datenschutzrichtlinie an sich eine Generalausnahme für Privatmutze hat. Ähm und die Fälle werden spannend. Also da wird's dann interessant, wie Unternehmen darauf reagieren,
und das ist wirklich in letzter Zeit das Problem gewesen, dass bei diesem Cloud Ding jeder gewusst hat, dass es rechtlich ein starker Graubereich ist, also bei jeder Konferenz, wo ich in den letzten Jahren war,
Sie gesagt, ja, sie können das schon machen mit Google Flaut, aber von einem Standpunkt ist es schwierig.
Und wenn jetzt die Farbe noch wegfällt, dann hat man ernsthaft das Problem. Und es geht ja wirklich so weit, dass bei uns,
Banken ihre E-Mail-Sachen auf Google ausgelagert haben, wo es einfach da stehst und da denkst, äh warum? Ja, weil's halt ein bissel billiger ist, als wie wenn man's selber machen, weil man halt den Server nicht vierundzwanzig Stunden ausgelastet kriegen in Österreich, weil man eben nur tagsüber arbeiten und dann steht er blöd herum und kostet uns Geld.
Und wenn man das auf Google auslagert und nicht laut machen, dann haben wir immer Kostenvorteile. Ähm.
Teilweise relativ problematisch ist, ähm war allen bewusst, aber man hat halt sich dacht wird schon nichts passieren. Und ich glaube, dass das jetzt die große Aufregung ist,
nach dem Urteil, dass man ein bisschen drauf kommt, so hoppo, leider kann ich's vielleicht doch irgendwas passieren, es könnte bisschen ungünstig werden.
Was erwartest du? Ich muss auch nochmal fragen, also was denkst du müsste jetzt, um mal erst mal bei Facebook zu bleiben, Facebook konkret für Maßnahmen einleiten, um jetzt gesetzeskonform zu sein?
Traurigerweise Facebook ist das, was am schwierigsten zu lösen ist. Das hat mich auch an dem Fall ein bisschen geärgert, weil ich gerne irgendwie bei so Sachen dann schreibe, so ist die Lösung,
Facebook haben das Grundproblem, dass er weltweit das Netzwerk ist und halt dich selber mal in den USA stehen. Das heißt, theoretisch können die A sagen, wir geben unsere steuersparende Präsenz in Irland auf und sind damit sozusagen einfach aus europäischer Sicht nicht mehr klagbar.
Und nicht mehr machbar. Es wäre im Prinzip jetzt äh reine Änderung in den AGB und halt in den vertraglichen Richtlinien,
Damit sind sie außerhalb der europäischen Juristik und keine machen, was sie wollen. Ähm.
Die andere Möglichkeit, dass die sozusagen jetzt nach Europa übersiedeln, was reonrealistisch ist. Also Facebook hat wirklich ein Pickel am Arsch.
Ähm weniger problematisch ist es bei Clouddiensten und Co, wo zum Beispiel Microsoft schon gesagt hat, gut,
Sachen bleiben in Europa, wir haben eine European Cloud und und da kämpfen wir auch dagegen, dass US zur Regierung drauf Zugriff hat und so weiter, ist natürlich immer eine Frage des Trusts, ob das wirklich so ist.
Die Sachen sind eher noch lösbar
Facebook ist ernsthaftes Problem, dass einfach weltweit verletzt ist. Also da kann ich dann einfach nicht sagen, da mache ich irgendwo eine rote Linie dazwischen, in der Cloud kann ich das noch eher machen, weil dann ist halt Unternehmen A auf dem Serverzentrum im Land X und Unternehmen B auf dem Serverzentrum in Land Y. Äh Facebook wird lustig.
Ja gut, aber was was heißt denn das jetzt sozusagen? Das heißt, wenn jetzt ein Deutscher dann äh äh Account hat, dann dann müssen die Bits in Europa liegen oder sie müssen nur in der in den USA genauso äh behandelt werden, als würden sie in Europa liegen.
Die Antwort kann ich jetzt so nicht geben. Ich glaube dauerhaft ähm ist die Lösung nur, dass man das politisch löst. Also die Überlegung hinter dem Fall ist ja zu einem großen Teil, das einfach so weit zu eskalieren, dass es nicht mehr ordentlich lösbar ist.
Außer Washington und EU setzt sich mal irgendwann zusammen und sagt gut, jetzt machen wir mal einen Deal zu dieser ganzen Massenüberwachungsthematik,
Meine Hoffnung halt im Hintergrund, dass jetzt ähm das halbe Silikon Valley am roten Teppich steht in, in, in, in Washington und.
Ähm und ihr müsst es irgendwie lösen. Und da ist halt leider diese alte Weisheit, dass man über die Wirtschaft oft weiterkommt als über freundliche Briten und auf einen diplomatischen Weg.
Ja, zum Beispiel Silicon Valley ja ohnehin schon ziemlich äh auf den Hinterbeinen steht, was die ganze Überwachungssituation betrifft. Also.
Also da ist man ja teilweise sogar mit denen im gleichen Boot, ne.
So, wir wissen, deine Zeit ist äh begrenzt eine ähm eine Frage, möchte ich aber trotzdem noch einen Raum schmeißen, weil jetzt natürlich diese ganze Grundfrage mit äh die Grundrechte für Datenschutz werden hier äh verletzt. Natürlich ja auch Auswirkungen haben kann auf,
andere äh Vereinbarungen, mir fällt da vor allem hier Passengerecord, PNR, also die Speicherung von Flugcast
äh Daten beziehungsweise deren Austausch mit den USA äh ein und natürlich auch Swift, also der Austausch von Finanztransaktionen, der ohnehin schon sehr äh umstritten ist. Ähm denkst du, dass das
äh auch auf solche Bereiche jetzt ein unmittelbarer Auswirkung hat, die Rechtsprechung?
Glaube unmittelbar nicht, weil jetzt, glaube ich, alle mit
mit genug beschäftigt sind, ähm aber dauerhaft natürlich schon. Also ähm ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, ich bin beim SWR Ding habe ich mir immer grob angeschaut, aber da muss man es wirklich genau in die Paragraphen gehen, wo steht, was drinnen und das neben das Urteil legen und sagen, was steht da?
Haben wir das dann jeweils in diesen anderen Abkommen auch drinnen. Ähm das wird auch spannend, aber es wird vor allem jetzt sozusagen die weitere Debatte zu den Dingern wahrscheinlich auch ähm.
Pushen. Ich glaube nur, dass es sozusagen in der Realität,
mal am Backburner landen, während diese anderen Dinge, weil die halt jetzt nicht so dominant sind und auch wirtschaftlich weniger relevant sind. Aber natürlich das Urteil, das ist das spannende Urteil, dass es auf Grundrechtsbasis ist. Das heißt, es fällt,
das Rational hinter diesem Urteil gilt für all diese Paragraphen, für all diese Abkommen, ziemlich egal, unter welchem, unter welchem Ding das genau läuft,
eben der Fehler, den Facebook jetzt gemacht hat, dass die gesagt haben, naja, wir haben ja eh Standardvertragsklausel und wenn Seefahrer uns wegfallt, dann haben wir noch immer die Standardvertragsklassen und das ist eben 'ne andere,
Daten in die USA zu transferieren. Aber natürlich gilt das Urteil für Standardvertragsklausel ganz genauso. Weil ob ich jetzt unter Paragraph A, Massenüberwachung mache oder unter Paragraph B ist aus grundrechtlicher Sicht vollkommen egal.
Und es wird durchaus spannend, also die alternativen, vor allem den Unternehmen dann wirklich weg, die da dabei sind. Und das wird lustig. Also.
Und wie geht's jetzt äh für dich weiter, wenn du dann mal äh endlich äh vor allen vor alle Kameras äh geschoben worden bist? Weltweit.
Ich habe eh schon, ich glaube, ich habe die Woche schon ich vom Land zu sonst, was alles mögliche abgesagt, weil ich soweit gar nicht mehr und ähm ja, ähm Doktor Rat weiterschreiben und Ruhe.
Na ja okay, kann ich mir vorstellen. Thomas, hast du noch Fragen?
Nee, nee, ich glaube, das war recht guter Einstieg in das Thema, ja. Ich hoffe, wir haben dich bald wieder. Also äh es wird ja weitergehen bei dir.
Okay Max, dann erstmal vielen Dank.
Wunderbar, bis dann.
Bis bald, tschüss.
So, das war der Max. Kommen wir äh zum nächsten Thema,
Thomas, was gibt's Neues äh aus Österreich, außer dass jetzt hier äh die Welt verklagt wird?
Ja, also das äh.
Das Tolle an Österreich ist ja, es ist so ein kleines Land, ähm und eigentlich recht unspannend, einem wird sogar ziemlich schnell langweilig und deswegen macht man viel internationales Zeug. So geht mir das ja auch mit der Netzneutralität in Europa.
Und da ähm stehen wir jetzt wirklich so kurz vorm Ziel. Äh ich weiß nicht, wann wir das letzte Mal drüber gesprochen haben, aber es wurde ja.
Ein Text ausverhandelt äh in diesem sogenannten Trilog zwischen den drei EU-Institutionen.
Vor der Sommerpause und äh die hat immer noch einige große Probleme, die uns Bauchschmerzen bereiten.
Trilog, damit ist gemeint, die Verhandlungslinie zwischen Kommission, Europäischem Rat und dem Europäischen Parlament. Mhm.
Und diese drei Unsinn haben sich da zusammengesetzt und Trilog ist an sich,
da gibt's sogar jetzt ein Verfahren vom Ombutzmann der EU äh äh weil die sagt, das ist extrem intransparent und extrem undemokratisch und damit hat sie Recht. So Trilog-Verhandlungen sind nämlich wirklich so, du hast davor einen
ordentlichen Gesetzgebungsprozess, wo Bürger einbezogen werden, zumindest theoretisch und Dinge sind transparent, es gibt offizielle Dokumente. An dem Trilog ist alles hinter verschlossenen Türen. Du weißt meistens nicht einmal, wer jetzt da wirklich am Tisch sitzt,
Und ähm das war auch dort der Fall. Also wenn man nicht irgendwie Leute kennt, die dort sitzen für eine Partei oder für eine Institution, dann hat man keine Ahnung mitzubekommen, äh worüber jetzt eigentlich verhandelt wird und,
das fertige Gesetz, das das kommt aus dem Trilog, die müssen sich einigen und ihre drei Standpunkte sozusagen auf einen Nenner bringen.
Und dass es da passiert ähm wirklich auch in einem Krimi um zwei Uhr früh ähm ist diese Einigung erzielt worden.
Ich glaube, ich komme mal diese Story erzählen ähm.
Wandeln jetzt überhaupt?
Das war äh Ende Juni, also sozusagen wirklich, glaube ich, dreißigste Juni, der letzte Tag der lettischen Ratspräsidentschaft, das wird ja dann mit.
Hälfte des Jahres ans nächste Land übergeben und die wollten halt unbedingt noch eine Einigung haben,
Und äh es waren schon irgendwie die Grünen und haben gesagt, nee, machen wir nicht mit. Die Liberalen sind aufgestanden. Äh die Linken waren sowieso nicht anwesend,
Und äh dann dann war irgendwie nur noch die Sozialdemokratie dort und da gab's auch irgendwie schon eine Verhandlungsführerin, die Kammer Ebert, die meinte so, nein, das geht überhaupt nicht. Und wir verhandeln hier nicht weiter. Die Vorbedingungen passen alle nicht,
Die andere Verhandlungsführerin der Sozialdemokraten stand mit ihrer Handtasche schon in der Tür, ja? Das war die letzte, die sozusagen, wenn die ja sagt, dann gibt's einen Deal, wenn die nein sagt, dann können wir mit mehr Zeit und mit mehr Ruhe weiter verhandeln,
Antis mit der Handtasche in der Tür gestanden und dann wurde ihr nochmal was für Roaming versprochen,
Hat sie bei einer Netzertralität nachgegeben, so sind wir zu dem Text gekommen, der jetzt hier am Tisch liegt.
Ähm und da wurden sozusagen die Artikel, wurden da Ende Juni festgezorrt, dann Anfang Juli gab's noch ein einziges Treffen, wo man noch über die Erwägungsgründe des Gesetzes gesprochen hat. Also die ganzen Erklärungen, wo auch Definitionen drinnen stehen.
Und da wurde ein bissel was noch repariert, aber es hat's nicht wirklich besser gemacht. Und wir wir haben stehen heute jetzt mit einem Text da.
Ja noch nicht wirklich gesetzt ist, aber der jetzt Ende ähm Oktober in zweiter Lesung durchs Parlament geht und wenn wir dort nichts tun, wenn's dort keine Änderungsanträge gibt, dann ist das so gesetzt und dann ist das die Netzzentralität, die wir in allen achtundzwanzig EU-Ländern,
diese halbe Milliarde Menschen haben werden.
Also im Sommer kurz äh zusammenzufassen, ne. Wir äh blicken ja jetzt hier auf einen Prozess, der schon wie lange läuft? Zwei Jahre.
Zweitausend im September zweitausenddreizehn ist das hat das angefangen, ja.
Genau. Und ähm
da gab's ja die damals ja wohl äh bejubelter und wir haben ja auch hier bei Lokbuch Netzpolitik viel drüber gesprochen, die äh Entscheidung des Parlaments, wie das wird der Netzneutralität eigentlich gehandhabt werden soll und
das war ja, sagen wir mal, ein Ergebnis, was sehr viel äh Freude bereitet hat und im Prinzip ist jetzt das Ganze im Rahmen dieser äh Trilogbesprechung,
aufgeweicht worden und geht jetzt in diese aufgeweichten Form wieder zurück ins Parlament. So, aber es könnte doch auch sein, dass das Parlament dem nicht zustimmt.
Genau, das ist jetzt äh äh auch der Punkt, wo wir ansetzen und wo wir gerade dran arbeiten, weil im Parlament, da sind halt gewählte Volksvertreter, äh mit denen man sprechen kann, die sich ihren Bürgern verantwortlich fühlen.
Und da versuchen wir jetzt in zweiter Lesung noch Änderungsanträge durchzubekommen. Für die Probleme, die dieser Text noch hat.
Ähm vielleicht bleiben wir beim Prozedere, also für diese Änderungsanträge braucht man zuerst mal die Zustimmung von Martin Schulz, vom Präsident des Europaparlaments.
Ähm das sollte nicht so ein Problem sein, weil es gab eine Wahl zwischen erster und zweiter Lesung, dann müssen diese Änderungsanträge von,
einer Fraktion oder vierzig Abgeordneten eingebracht werden. Da glauben wir auch, das kriegen wir locker hin. Ähm und dann werden sie abgestimmt mit einer absoluten Mehrheit.
Absolute Mehrheit heißt, dass ich nicht einfach nur von allen Abgeordneten, die jetzt grade im Plenum sitzen, die Hälfte aller Hände nach oben gehen müssen, sondern es müssen die Hälfte von.
Allen Abgeordneten,
auch die, die nicht anwesend sind. Das heißt, von den siebenhunderteinundfünfzig Abgeordneten brauche ich halt einfach äh fünfzig Prozent plus eins. Das heißt, ich brauche äh dreihundertsechsundsiebzig Stimmen.
Das ist immer grundsätzlich so, wenn ein äh Gesetz äh also wenn der sozusagen äh darüber abgestimmt wird, was jetzt die finale Vorlage ist für die Trilog-Verhandlung.
Genau, also das ähm sozusagen du hast ja die erste Lesung, das das Gesetz kommt von der Kommission,
Ähm dann geht es in Parlament und Rat. Die bilden sich ihre Meinung in erster Lesung.
Und dann geht's in den Trilog, da sagt man sozusagen aus diesen ersten Lesungen, die das den gemeinsamen Nenner, die gemeinsame Position, die verhandelt wird und die geht dann in die zweite Lesung.
Und in zweiter Lesung kann man entweder sagen, äh ja, passt, wird Gesetz, nein, weg damit.
Beenden den Prozess und damit ist das Teil auch gestorben. Oder wir machen nochmal Änderungsanträge.
Nochmal Änderungsanträge heißt, wir gehen ihnen noch eine neue Runde Trilog-Verhandlungen.
Und da können wir uns auch wieder einig werden oder nicht. Und am Ende wird was ausverhandelt, dass dann in dritte Lesung geht und auch da kann man äh ähm nochmal ja oder nein sagen, Änderungsanträge gibt's in dritter Lesung aber nicht mehr.
Das ist ein binärer Vot, ja.
Ja, okay, verstehe. Das heißt, man könnte aber im Prinzip jetzt auch sagen, äh wir wollen das überhaupt nicht, aber das ist jetzt eher unwahrscheinlich, dass es dazu kommt.
Also im Parlament ist es unwahrscheinlich, weil einfach Roaming und Netzzentralität ja die zwei Themen sind in diesem Gesetz,
und Roaming ist für die EU etwas, das äh in in breiten Teilen der Bevölkerung Wellen schlägt und das war auch Wahlkampfthema, als in ähm Mai zweitausendvierzehn, das Europaparlament gewählt wurde, ging's auch für viele Abgeordnete darum, dass sie vorher noch Roaming,
Abgeschafft haben und sich feiern haben lassen. Das heißt, für die ist das ein Wahlversprechen, das werden sie versuchen zu retten und umzusetzen.
Treppenwitz, wir erinnern uns, Roaming war ja immer so, dass das Tauschthema, ja? Wir wir nehmen euch das Roaming weg und dafür gebt ihr uns bei der Netzzentralität was. Das war der Deal mit den Providern.
An das Perfide ist jetzt aber, dass in diesem Text Roaming in Wirklichkeit
ähm weiterhin bestehen wird. Es gibt nur eine basic free Aloons. Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt irgendwie nach Italien gehe äh als Deutscher und dann äh zurück nach Hause telefoniere, äh ein paar Minuten, paar Megabyte habe ich frei. Danach gibt's immer noch Roaminggebü,
und wenn ich als Deutscher in Deutschland mit meinem deutschen Handy nach Frankreich anrufe, auch dann gibt's immer noch Roaming.
Also es ist halt bei weitem nicht so, dass wir an den Grenzen nicht mehr merken, dass wir jetzt eine Grenze überschritten haben. Ähm und dass wir wirklich als Europa zusammenrücken,
Ähm es ist halt gerade eben die die paar Urlauber, die es gibt, die sind aus der Debatte raus und das wird eher dazu beitragen, dass wir
Roaming auf lange Sicht noch behalten werden und nicht, dass es äh endlich abgeschafft wird.
Und hast du den Eindruck, dass das im Parlament auch auch so gesehen wird, dass hier eigentlich äh keine nennenswerten Fortschritte erzielt worden sind? Also ich meine, wenn man noch nicht mal das Ruming losgeworden ist und die Netzneutralität stimmt auch nicht. Ich meine, dann ist das ja wirklich ein schlechter Deal, ne.
Eine Rede. Das ist meine Rede. Es ist halt wirklich nicht gut gemacht und man hat halt in beiden Themen so.
Komm, lass uns Netzwerk beschließen, komm, lass uns Roaming beschließen, egal, was da dann drinnen steht. Ähm und es wird halt wirklich in vielen Teilen nicht, nicht hingeschaut.
Äh und da äh ja hätte ich mir auch mehr Unterstützung von den Konsumentenschützern erhofft. Die wissen auch alle, was in dem Text drinnen steht. Aber es gibt halt so dieses ja,
das Ding ist eh ausverhandelt, passt schon, gehen wir weiter zu Digital Market, zu den neuen Projekten und keiner will sich jetzt mit dem Zeug noch aufhalten,
wäre das aber wirklich desaströs, weil was da jetzt im Text drinnen steht, würde im europäischen Internet Dinge erlauben, die wir wahrscheinlich dann.
Nie wieder wegbekommen.
Ist ja auch ein bisschen absurd, weil jetzt eigentlich über diesen ganzen Verlauf der Debatte mit der Netzneutralität ähm sicher das Blatt in den USA komplett gewendet hat,
ja? Und äh weiß nicht, wie dein Eindruck ist, aber ich wäre jetzt auch nicht so überrascht gewesen, dass viel Argumentation.
In Europa ja dann auch eigentlich immer ne, grade wenn's um Internet geht, zeigt man ja schnell in die USA und da war ja so tendenziell eben auch immer noch die Debatte um eine äh entsprechende Verschärfung und Specialist Services et cetera äh spricht zu dem Zeitpunkt, als ich hier die Gesetzesentwürfe manifestiert haben
und man, wenn man nach USA blickte, sehte man so, ja, wieso, die machen das doch auch. Jetzt ist es aber eigentlich genau andersrum
dass die USA sozusagen die Kurve bekommen haben und irgendwie begriffen haben so, ja, nee, das schadet uns. Äh aber die Europäer jetzt quasi äh äh blind in ihr Verderben laufen und äh genau das Gegenteil beschließen.
Ja, das ist das ist halt auch wieder so ein Treppenwitz, ja. Ich meine, als wir angefangen haben, ähm zweitausenddreizehn sah es so aus, dass die.
Da gab's ja noch die alten Regeln in den USA, die dann aufgehoben wurden, das heißt so, immer wenn's in Europa gut ausgesehen hat, hat es in den USA schlecht ausgesehen oder umgekehrt.
Aber es war nie beide auf der selben äh Seite und abwechselnd hat man dann von Lobbyisten gehört, schaut auch in den USA, ist Netznetralität, das hält dort nicht, das braucht man nicht,
und jetzt wo die USA wirklich gute Regeln haben, hört man von allen Telekom-Lobbyisten. Der amerikanische Markt ist nicht zu vergleichen mit dem europäischen und die haben ja viel mehr Olympohle und viel mehr Netzzentralitätsverletzungen
Also es sind halt Ausflüchte. In Wirklichkeit natürlich haben die USA hier einen Goldstandard gesetzt und
Thema wird halt gerade weltweit verhandelt, also in Brasilien, in Mexiko, wartet man, ähm also da ist man in der Implementierungsphase der dortigen Gesetze, da wird immer noch viel ausverhandelt in den Details, in Indien überlegt man sich in Netzzentralitätsgesetz zu machen, jetzt auf dem äh IGF in Brasilien wird das ein riesiges Thema sein,
also Netzertralität führt grade wirklich global ausverhandelt.
Natürlich schauen viele Länder auch nach Europa. Ähm wenn wenn die EU jetzt hier eine schlechte Entscheidung trifft, dann wird das,
Grund für vor allem viele Länder des globalen Südens sein, sich dann nicht an den USA, sondern an Europa zu orientieren.
Mhm.
Weil die Europäer argumentieren das ja auch so,
Dieser amerikanischen Diensteanbieter, die sind auf die verbrauchen so viel von unserer Internetinfrastruktur, die sollen noch etwas für den Ausbau dieser Infrastruktur zahlen,
kompetierenrissiges Argument, was man an vielen Eigen widerlegen kann, weil's halt einfach falsche Investitionsanreize setzt, wenn ich eine Knappheit monetarisieren kann.
Aber das das ist so gerade eben der Anti-USA-Ansatz, der in in Gefahr steht, in Europa zu siegen.
Was hast du denn äh für einen Eindruck, wer da jetzt so die treibenden äh äh Kräfte sind und auf jeden Fall jetzt noch Einfluss genommen werden kann und sollte.
Also äh es geht um Änderungsanträge im Europaparlament. Das ist unser Hebel, das sind wir stark. Ähm dort müssen wir vor allem,
ähm die Sozialdemokraten, die Linken,
die Grünen und auch die Paliberalen die es noch gibt die auf die würde ich mich jetzt mal so aus deutscher Perspektive konzentrieren. Es geht um eine absolute Mehrheit. Das heißt wir haben eigentlich nicht den Luxus
ähm uns nur auf eine linke Mehrheit zu stützen, sondern wir müssen wirklich mit allen sprechen, um genügend Stimmen zu bekommen.
Ähm und Safety Internet Punkt EU ist äh wieder aktuell, liefert wieder genau die Tools, die man braucht, um das zu tun.
Ähm das heißt, es ist auch keine eine Ausrede, wieso man nicht in diesem Thema jetzt nochmal aktiv werden will.
Ähm und äh wie gesagt, das Europaparlament, das sind auch Leute, mit denen man sprechen kann, die kann man anrufen, gerade die Assistenten dort sind alles irgendwie äh junge gut gebildete, doch meist sehr weltoffene Menschen,
ähm und wenn man denen erklärt, schaut, das ist wichtig und ihr habt das schon mal getan und es wird Änderungsanträge geben und ihr müsst nur die richtige, einen richtigen Moment die Hände hochheben.
Ähm dann wird man auf jeden Fall nochmal eine eine gute Chance haben, hier noch was zu bewegen.
Ähm was ich jetzt noch nicht erklärt habe, ist, was eigentlich jetzt noch das Problem in Netzneutralität ist. Ähm weil es ist nämlich ein neues Problem dazugekommen,
Wir erinnern uns noch, Spezialdienste sind sind äh jetzt in dem in dem aktuellen Text schlecht definiert, sodass bestehender Online-Dienst auf einmal,
Überholspur eines Spezialdienstes bekommen kann.
Also ökonomische Diskriminierung, da wo wie die Deutsche Telekom das mit Spotify macht, einzelne Dienste aus meinem monatlichen Volumen ausgeschlossen werden und auch wenn das Volumen verbraucht ist, kann ich noch Musikstreaming hören,
diese Form der Diskriminierung ist auch noch erlaubt und der dritte neue Punkt ist Glaspace Traffic Management.
Am Internet wird in Europa ja oft,
Bestford übersetzt. Best FORD, das äh Netzneutralität wird in Europa oft mit Bestord übersetzt, also dass Daten einfach genauso gut übertragen werden, äh wie man kann und ich ich äh greife als Provider jetzt nicht ein und priorisiere meine eigenen Daten
irgendwie meine Konkurrenz. Dieses Best-Efod-Prinzip wird eigentlich abgeschafft mit diesem Text.
Weil ich dann die Möglichkeit habe, als Internetprovider herzugehen und zu sagen, ich habe hier fünf Traff-Klassen. Und die Traffic Klasse, ich habe mal irgendwie goldpremium,
und extra langsam. Ich kann die nicht vermarkten. Ich kann da nicht ein Businessmodell draus machen, aber ich kann einfach sagen, Videostreaming ist wichtig. Ähm zeitkritische Dienste sind wichtig, werden immer priorisiert.
Webbrowsing ist eher langsam, das ist das ist in der mittleren Prioritätsklasse, sagen wir mal so drei von fünf und dann habe ich aber auch noch so äh.
E-Mail-Dienste, verschlüsselte Dienste, Dinge, die ich nicht einsortieren kann und die gebe ich in die letzte Qualitätsklasse,
Also alles, was jetzt an unbekanntes, neues Protokoll ist, alles, was vielleicht ist, auch wenn gerade da zum Beispiel Bitcoin,
oder betreuend Videostreaming über das Protokoll gefahren wird, dann ähm werde ich das auch in die schlechteste Qualitätsklasse einsortieren,
Also dieses Glas bis Traffic Management, auch wenn es nicht dazu taugt, ein Geschäftsmodell damit zu machen, hat immer noch große Probleme, wenn's darum geht, die Neutralität und Offenheit des Internets zu behalten.
Und ähm das wird eben ermöglicht mit den derzeitigen Text und das wirklich so reingeschlichen worden, keine vorherigen Institutionen haben das eigentlich in ihrer eigenen Position gehabt, aber es ist halt wirklich in diesen spätabendlichen Verhandlungen rein,
gebracht worden als Text. Und da müssen wir auf jeden Fall kämpfen, dass das verhindert wird, weil was mache ich, wenn ich ein neues Protokoll entwickle oder einen neuen Dienst,
und irgendein portugiesischer Provider äh gibt mich in die falsche Qualitätsklasse,
wie verhandele ich, dass ich da in die richtige reinkomme? Was ist wenn das ein Open-Source-Protokoll ist? Wer verhandelt dann dafür?
Was ist mit dem ganzen verschlüsselten Traffic, der vielleicht nicht kategorisierbar ist.
Es gibt Beispiele im Plus NET in Großbritannien, auch belgische Provider, die schon so ein klassenbasiertes Netzwerkmanagement haben.
Und äh das ist für ganz Europa, wenn wir in die Richtung gehen, halt wirklich eben genau das Gegenteil von dem, wie sie es in den USA gemacht haben und äh hat äh jetzt eben wirklich auch große Auswirkungen auf die Innovationsfähigkeit des Netzes.
Äh finde ich aber jetzt einen interessanten Gedanken, den du da gerade geäußert hast. Ich weiß nicht, ob der äh äh in eurer Argumentation auch schon eine größere Rolle gespielt hat, aber die nicht klassifizierbarkeit von verschlüsselten Traffic.
Im Hinblick auf die den potentiellen Anstieg von verschlüsselten Trappic. Ja, also gerade jetzt mit äh neuen
Mechanismen, die in den nächsten Monaten ausgerollt werden, wie zum Beispiel diese Kampagne. Ich denke, wir werden da einen signifikanten äh Anstieg sehen im im Kryptobereich beziehungsweise auch die,
komplett Verschlüsselung in großer äh Dienste, die ja mittlerweile auch Standard ist, äh
weiß nicht ganz genau, wie weit äh WhatsApp äh vorangekommen ist, aber über kurz oder lang äh wird es einfach noch mehr sein und das heißt, dass es betrifft ja dann im Prinzip alle Dienste. Also gerade diese Argumentation mit.
Ähm.
Ja, ihr seid ja nur ein unwichtiger Dienst. Ja und es gibt da keine Masse, äh in dem Moment, wo man nicht mehr klassifizieren kann, weil zu sehr verschlüsselt, äh ne, gerade wenn's alles ohnehin über Web äh äh Protokolle geht
äh in dem Moment ist ja jeder ausgegrenzt und da muss man sich wahrscheinlich schon mal darüber Gedanken machen. Aber wahrscheinlich stellen die Leute sich das halt immer noch so vor, dass man sich einfach äh den entsprechenden Sportwagen kauft in Form äh des des entsprechenden Netzzugangs. Aber innerhalb der Netze äh selbst ist das natürlich äh in dem Sinne gar nicht zu lösen.
Genau und äh das das äh da sind einfach noch ganz viele äh wirklich stinkende Eiterpollen in diesem Gesetz, wo halt auch schlecht gearbeitet wurde. Also man hat ganz oft äh Widersprüche auch im Text, dass dass man sagt so.
Äh der das eine oder andere Seite sagt, A, das andere Seite, sagt B und das geht logisch aber nicht zusammen,
Das ist halt wirklich so ein Kompromisstext und in vielen Punkten äh sagen auch äh inzwischen alle Rechtsmeinungen
ist das so offen, wie dir dann von den Regulierungsbehörden am Ende ausgelegt wird, also auch bei bei Spezialdiensten ist es so, das könnte man auch positiv lesen. Jetzt eine gute,
äh wirklich motivierte Regulierungsbehörde könnte sagen, nein, also es äh irgendwie so Skype Ultra hat, die ihr Spezialdienst, nein, das geht nicht,
aber es kann genauso auch in Regulierungsbehörde hergehen und sagen, natürlich, ja, wir machen hier den ganzen Markt auf. Und.
Genau diese Unschärfe im im Gesetzestext, die wird mit einem Arbeitsschritt, der
Ähm danach kommt beseitigt. Also wir haben sozusagen jetzt die eine Möglichkeit, Änderungsanträge noch reinzukriegen am, am siebenundzwanzigsten, achtundzwanzigsten Oktober, wenn das Ganze in Straßburg abgestimmt wird. Ähm egal, ob wir da gewinnen oder verlieren.
Passiert dann ein äh ähm Prozess, wo die europäischen Regulierungsbehörden sich alle zusammensetzen und nochmal Guidelines schreiben
die genau definieren, wie dieses Gesetz jetzt gemeint ist. Das heißt, es sind nicht gewählte Regulierungsbehörden, die Bundesnetzagentur für Deutschland, die RTR für Österreich, aufkommen für Großbritannien, die kommen alle zusammen
und äh geben dann dem Gesetz wirklich eine konkrete Bedeutung, die es jetzt noch nicht hat, weil jetzt kann ich's so oder so lesen.
Und äh diese Guideline Creation ist äh für uns deswegen auch ein ganz wichtiger Schritt.
Wo wir uns auch einbringen werden. Es wird da eine Konsultation geben, also es kann äh Hinz und Kunz und alle Menschen ihre Meinung sagen, ähm wie dieses Gesetz jetzt äh gemeint sein soll und und wieso dieses oder jenes wichtig und richtig für die Gesellschaft ist.
Ähm und da müssen wir uns auf jeden Fall auch nochmal einbringen.
Ähm da wird's dann auch auf Safety Internet noch mehr Informationen geben, wenn's soweit ist. Und äh das ist halt wichtig. Wir sehen halt,
eben in in Brasilien und in Mexiko sind wir gerade in dieser Phase. Da ist das Gesetz beschlossen und jetzt gehen die Regulierer her und überlegen sich, was heißt das denn eigentlich konkret?
In den USA was anders. Dort hat der Regulierer ja das Gesetz geschrieben. Deswegen ist das amerikanische Gesetz auch so gut, weil's wirklich äh
hundert Seiten lang hat. Äh und, und, und nicht wie das Niederländische, was fünf Seiten hat oder das äh Europäische, was so ungefähr auf zwanzig kommt.
Was ist denn dein Eindruck, wie die äh Netzagenturen, sage ich mal, äh dazu stehen. Also welcher welcher Konsens lässt sich denn da, also gibt's da überhaupt einen Konsens? Und und wenn ja, äh irgendwelche Tendenz schlägt das aus?
Ähm also das ist sehr unterschiedlich, womit wem man spricht. Äh es gibt sehr gute Regulierungsbehörden, die sehr motiviert sind. Ähm äh vor allem eben auch in kleineren Ländern und dann gibt es solche, ja, Behörden wie
ähm Offcom in Großbritannien ist so wirklich der Teufel, also die die versuchen alles um ja nichts zu tun.
Und die sind auch große Feinde der Netznetralität. Ähm an sich lässt sich das äh die Ausrichtung der ähm.
Der Regulierungsbehörden ziemlich nah an der Ausrichtung der Regierungen immer im Rat äh ablesen. Also die Länder, die
ähm im Rat gegen Netzzentralität waren, die haben auch meistens Regulierungsbehörden, die gegen Netzneutalität sind. Ähm der Vorteil ist so ein bisschen, dass innerhalb von diesem Gremium an europäischen Regulierungsbehörden. Berg nennt sich das,
äh jedes Land eine Stimme hat. Und im Rat ist es ja so, dass die großen Länder mehr Gewicht haben, mehr Stimmrecht haben. Ähm gleichzeitig
Ressourcen sind natürlich trotzdem ungleich verteilt, also kleine Länder wie Österreich, die kommen da vielleicht mit zwei Leuten hin, haben vielleicht noch eine Person, die,
halbtags irgendwie das die Verhandlungen verfolgt und äh,
kommen dort mit einem Verhandlungsteam von fünf Leuten und haben zwanzig Leute in London sitzen, die alles Myron und die ganze Zeit, die Verhandlungen äh begleiten. Also das wird wirklich ein interessanter Prozess. Auch die Kommission muss sich da einbringen
ihr habt da auch Mitspracherecht, das einzige Player. Und äh das das wird sozusagen auch nochmal,
Ein Detailkampf, den wir führen müssen. Aber jetzt sind wir noch im Gesetzgebungsprozess. Jetzt haben wir noch die Chance, den Text an sich zu verbessern.
Dass wir halt einfach um um Welten besser und erfolgsversprechender als sich jetzt schon auf die Guidelines zu konzentrieren.
Genau, das kann noch eine Weile hin sein. Ähm müssen wir halt mal schauen, ob's noch zu einer äh dritten Lesung äh kommt. Halte ich jetzt mal nicht für komplett ausgeschlossen.
Hängt jetzt vor allem erstmal von der Aktivität ab, die jetzt noch im Parlament entsteht, um genug.
Änderungsvorschläge durchzubringen.
Uh
Haben wir das damit ähm.
Ja, das war, das war sozusagen das Update zur Netzertalität.
Mhm.
Ähm äh ja, es,
bleiben. Es gibt auch einen schönen Countdown auf Safety Internet, wo man dann äh sich aktivieren kann, dadurch, dass jetzt noch neunzehn Tage, achtzehn Stunden und achtundzwanzig Minuten übrig bleiben.
Ähm das sollte äh Motivation genug sein. Ähm,
Ja und dann hätte ich noch ein anderes Thema, äh was mir sehr wichtig ist, äh zurück nach Österreich, äh das Staatsschutzgesetz, darüber habe ich mit Finus äh ja schon mal auch gesprochen, als wir als wir äh ein LMP dazu gemacht haben.
Ich weiß jetzt aber nicht mehr, welche Folge das war.
Das finde ich noch raus.
Ähm ja, was tut man irgendwie im Jahr zwei nach Snowden? Man schafft einen neuen Inlandsgeheimdienst.
Ähm also Österreich plant grade mit dem Staatsschutzgesetz äh eben so einen neue Überwachungsbehörde, die auch mehr oder weniger genau das tut, was jetzt auch in diesem Seehaber-Urteil kritisiert wurde, nämlich diese anlasslose Massenüberwachung.
Und da äh ist der Ackervorrat Österreich sehr stark dahinter mit einer Kampagne auf WWW Staatsschutz Punkt AT,
Äh und da, die haben schon sechzehntausend Menschen unterstützt äh
kann jeder machen ähm und an sich ist dieses Gesetz halt einfach eines, was
von ganz vielen Seiten kritisiert wurde. Also da haben irgendwie die Richtervereinigungen, die Bischöfe, die Arbeiterkammer, die Wirtschaftskammer, der Verfassungsdienst, des Bundeskanzleramtes, alle haben die Hände übern Kopf zusammengeschlagen,
geschrieben, wie könnt ihr nur ähm das ist halt wirklich von Hardlinern aus dem Innenministerium geschrieben und sozusagen der,
Wunsch jetzt mal alle Hemmnisse für Überwachung in Österreich aus dem Weg zu räumen,
eine große Datenbank, in die kommt alles rein, es gibt kein Richter Vorbehalt mehr,
ich kann eigentlich jeden überwachen, ähm auch Leute, die überhaupt nicht verdächtig sind, von diesen nicht verdächtigen Personen auch noch das soziale Umfeld, die Begleitung Kontaktpersonen,
an alle Daten, die ich da sammle, werden dann auch an andere Geheimdienste ausgetauscht.
Äh und äh solche V-Leute, wie sie ihm in den NSU-Morden verwendet wurden, die führen wir auch in Österreich ein mit diesem Gesetz.
Gibt's einen Namen für diesen äh Dienst, der da entstehen soll?
Ähm also das ist der der Staatsschutz.
Äh und äh der besteht aus den äh Behörden des äh BVT und der LVs, des Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz und Terrorismusbekämpfung und der Landesämter für Verfassungsschutz
es ist ein bissel ähnlich wie die der Verfassungsschutz in Deutschland, wobei das in Österreich jetzt eine Polizeibehörde ist,
und sie bekommt dann die Befugnisse eines Geheimdienstes.
Leider in Österreich kein Trennungsgebot wie in Deutschland zwischen Polizei und Geheimdiensten mit diesem Gesetz bräuchten wir aber eigentlich eines, ähm anstatt sowas zu machen, verschieben sie's halt wirklich auf eine Behörde, die die dann eigentlich wirklich so wie ein Geheimdienst,
die bekommt das abstrakte Risikoszenario auf dem Tisch, es gibt radikale Tierschützer,
Und äh deswegen fangen wir jetzt an, alles zu überwachen und nach radikalen Tierschützern zu suchen. Und wenn wir dann welche finden, äh dann geben wir keine abstrakte,
Äh an keinen abstrakten Lagebericht weiter, sondern dann äh zeigen wir diese Leute gleich an und und äh leiten konkrete Ermittlungsschritte gegen diese Menschen ein. Also da ist halt auch genau das, weswegen man Geheimdienste und Polizei trennt überhaupt nicht bedacht.
Ja und das Gesetz äh es wird jetzt äh wurde schon zweimal verschoben, äh weil's so viel Protest gab.
Ah und jetzt äh wird der Protest auch langsam manifest im Parlament. Äh wir hatten letztens eine sehr tolle Diskussionsveranstaltung.
Mit den Justizsprechern von der ganzen Opposition und die Opposition ist geschlossen dagegen und auch die SPÖ, also die sozialdemokratische Regierungspartei, die in den Bundeskanzler stellt, ist in Teilen dagegen,
Da äh hatten wir den Justizsprecher, den Hannes Jarolim am Podium und der meinte auch, also mit ihm gibt's dieses Gesetz nicht und äh er hat da große, große Bedenken,
und äh die SPÖ sozusagen immer noch uneinig in diesem Thema.
Das ist aus einem anderen Grund sehr spannend, weil wir sehen in Österreich, dass das Parlament sich ein bisschen auf die Hinterbeine stellt bei dieser ganzen Überwachungsmaschinerie.
Ähm es es gab schon mal eine Resolution vor das Parlament, geschlossen die Regierung aufgefordert hat, jetzt endlich etwas wegen der Snoden-Affäre zu machen. Und alle Schritte in die Wege zu leiten, die Bevölkerung vor der Tätigkeit ausländischer Geheimdienste zu schützen.
Ähm hier ist es auch so, die Regierung hat das Gesetz durchgewinkt. Auch die ähm sozialdemokratischen Ministerien,
und jetzt ist aber im Parlament die Abgeordneten haben alle Bammel und sagen so nah, eigentlich wollen wir das nicht, also es ist für ein Land wie Österreich, wo eigentlich immer der Klubzwang herrscht und wo das Parlament eigentlich nur
Ausfüll äh Ausführungsgehilfe der Regierung ist, haben wir relativ großen Widerstand,
Das ist sehr unüblich für Österreich und ich finde das sehr bezeichnend, dass das eben grade beim Geheimdienstthema passiert und bei bei so einer undemokratischen Gesetzesvorlage.
Ja, interessant. Ähm meine wem also du hast ja gerade erwähnt, ne, dieses äh Trennungsgebot zwischen Polizei und äh Geheimdiensten, was ist in in Deutschland gibt?
Das ist ja nicht so.
Dass das mal einfach sich irgendjemand so ausgedacht hat, sondern dass es halt explizit gedacht, um eben so eine Bildung, wie äh man sie damals in der Nazizeit mit der äh Gestapo, nämlich der,
geheimen Staatspolizei hatte, zu verhindern. Weil in dem Moment, wo man sozusagen äh,
Undercover, also geheime, äh im geheimen stattfindende Maßnahmen kombiniert eben auch noch mit so einer
ähm durchführenden äh polizeilichen Tätigkeit in dem Moment übernimmt man halt die vollkommene Kontrolle und genau diese Trennung von auf der einen Seite nachrichtendienstlichen Ermittlungen, die aber so erstmal nur so informell sind
damit man halt Bescheid weiß, aber dann eben der Aktivität der Polizei. Auf der anderen Seite, das sollte halt getrennt werden, gerade um einen Übergriff des Staates,
verhindern, so wie er im Prinzip das ganze Grundgesetz ähm der Bundesrepublik Deutschland immer so in diesem,
Mantra geschrieben wurde man muss halt den Bürger vor dem Staat schützen weil hat sich ja gezeigt,
genug Anlass da äh entsprechende Bedenken zu haben. Ähm und jetzt kommt sowas wie eine Staats.
Staatsschutz auf in in Österreich. Werden solche Diskussionen angenommen in Österreich? Ist es.
Oder oder es ist halt einfach, weil die Nazis ja ideale Deutsche waren.
Ähm ja, also das ist äh man muss schon leider, äh ich ich beneide die Deutschen um das Grundgesetz, ganz ehrlich.
Es ist halt bei in Österreich weitaus weniger darauf bedacht genommen worden,
eine eine kluge Architektur diesem Staate zugrunde zu legen und man war halt mehr darauf bedacht, diese neutrale, schuldfreie Zone zu schaffen zwischen Ost und West und äh wo dann die Geheimdienste sich auch spielen können,
Wir haben ja die entsprechenden Gesetze, die das straffrei stellen, aber wir haben eben nicht so diesen.
Diesem Gedanken, dass man eben den Bürger vor dem Staat schützen muss, wie du das ja richtig gesagt hast und was, was jetzt wirklich eine Gewaltentrennung ist und ähm wie man auch ähm Pluralismus äh und und Extremismus ähm.
Immer da umgehen muss damit, dass das eben in einer Gesellschaft auch auf lange Sicht ein bissel resistent darüber ist. Ähm also da.
Ist in Österreich leider äh vieles nicht vorhanden. Wir haben auch keine gute,
Also die Bundesverfassung in Österreich liest sich wie ein Kochrezept wieder in den Staat aufbaust, aber nicht wofür steht, äh nicht, was er eigentlich will. Ähm und das ist an sich, was das äh ja, das das fehlt uns leider. Und,
Ich meine, auch mit diesem Gesetz, ich meine.
Es heißt ja auch schon Staatsschutz, ja, der, der Staatsschutz, der schützt ja wirklich nur den Staat, nicht mehr die Verfassung, nicht die Bevölkerung, sondern den Staat, seine Institutionen und ihre Funktionsfähigkeit.
Und er kümmert sich um Verfassungsgefährdende Angriffe.
Die aber auch äh ursprünglich Demonstrationstatbestände waren oder jetzt immer noch zum Beispiel Landesverrat, Geheimnisverrat Büssebleing, ist auch alles ein Verfassungsgefährder Angriff. Also da wird auch irgendwie so, da wird ganz viel zum Terrorismus erklärt,
was eigentlich äh äh ganz normale Straftaten sind und ähm auch äh gewisse Straftaten werden nur dann eben zu Verfassungsgefährdeten angreifen, wenn sie aus religiösen und weltanschaulichen Motivationen begangen werden.
Eine weltanschauliche Motivation hab ich immer.
Ja, das will man wohl meinen. Aha.
Mindestens nach den Regeln des Karmas, wenn ich jetzt glaube, mir steht mehr zu, auch dann habe ich eine weltanschauliche Motivation,
und äh äh natürlich auch Religion ist jetzt auch kein Schwernisgrund, wenn jemand irgendjemand anderen aus religiösen Um äh Gründen bestiehlt oder so, dann,
dann ist es auch noch kein Ding, ja? Und deswegen haben ja auch die Bischofskonferenz und die evangelische Kirche auch gesagt, äh äh das ist das falsche Abgrenzungskriterium und hust, hust, was ist mit unserem Beichtgeheimnis? Das nimmt ihr uns ja auch gerade weg.
Ähm also die die Kritik war wirklich aus allen Teilen der Gesellschaft damals, das das hat uns auch sehr bestärkt und das wirkt immer noch nach.
Und es ist halt auch zum ersten Mal, wo ich sehe, so okay,
Wir haben jetzt echt eine große Mobilisierung. Wir haben viele Leute, die in Österreich gegen dieses Gesetz inzwischen aktiv werden. Und da ähm.
Ja, da äh äh habe ich durchaus noch Hoffnung, dass wir es schaffen, dass das jetzt im parlamentarischen Prozess äh entweder komplett abgeschafft wird oder mit Änderungsanträgen noch so weit
alle Giftzähne gezogen werden. Das ist dann halt wirklich den Namen verdient in einem polizeilichen Staatsschutzgesetzes, was keine Geheimdienste mehr beinhaltet.
Ähm das hast du gesagt, die Abstimmung ist zum zweiten Mal verschoben worden. Ist sie erstmal auf unbestimmte Zeit oder auf ein konkretes Datum äh verschoben worden?
Auf unbestimmte Zeit, dass es in Österreich auch wieder sehr super
man erfährt das dann irgendwann kurzfristig, wann etwas auf die Tagesordnung kommt. Im Moment steht's noch nicht fest. Es wird wahrscheinlich am achtundzwanzigsten Oktober einen Innenausschuss geben, wo dieses Gesetz beschlossen äh werden soll oder wo mal im Ausschuss drüber verhandelt werden soll. Das hat auch die Frage, wie durchsetzungsstark sind die Abgeordneten
noch ein geben, wie viele Änderungsanträge gibt's im im Ausschuss schon.
Ähm das ist sozusagen der erste Schritt und im November wär dann eben das Plenum, das frühestmögliche wo man es beschließen könnte, ein Treppenwitz noch, ja.
Achtundzwanzigsten Oktober,
der Innenausschuss eigentlich vom amerikanischen Kongress über die Geheimdiensttätigkeit der NSE sprechen sollen und die Bedenken der österreichischen Bevölkerung, dem amerikanischen Kongress ausdrücken,
und dieser Termin, wo Österreich sozusagen im Nachgang dieses Ganzes auf die Hinterbeine stellen, in den USA vollständig wird. Der Termin muss jetzt wahrscheinlich abgesagt werden, weil die Innenministerin,
das Staatsschutzgesetz, also den Ausbau der eigenen Überwachung,
lieber haben will. Ähm das das zeigt schon sehr, wo die Prioritäten liegen. Ähm und äh auch schön, wenn das Gesetz dann wirklich im elften, zwölften November beschlossen werden sollte,
Ähm zwölfter November neunzehnhundertachtzehn ist der Tag, wo die erste Republik ausgerufen wurde, also für Österreich die absolute Monarchie abgeschafft hat,
vielleicht jetzt zum selben Tag auch wieder abgeschafft.
Ja, der AK Vorrat äh macht da entsprechend ähm.
Stimmung gegen diese Gesetzespläne? Gibt's da irgendetwas, den man sich konkret anschließen sollte? Außer der allgemeinen Diskussion.
Ja, also äh WWW Punkt Staatsschutzer T ist so die die Kampagnenseite, da findet man mehr oder weniger alles, oder AKVAT, das ist eben die äh Web,
der NGO, für die ich auch arbeite, das ist äh ich ich äh habe hier zum ersten Mal auch wirklich ähm mache das hauptberuflich für diese Kampagne. Europäisch ist natürlich auch
wichtig, aber da hast du halt immer ein großes Netzwerk von verschiedenen Playern,
hier ist wirklich auch ein tolles Team dahinter und es gibt inzwischen ganz viele Materialien, auf die ich stolz bin, die erklären, wo liegt das Problem, wer hat sich alle geäußert,
Das ist auf jeden Fall einen Blick wert.
Man kann die Petition unterstützen, damit leistet man auch einen Beitrag. Äh wie gesagt, das haben schon sechzehntausend Menschen gemacht. Das können noch viel mehr werden.
Gut, das werden wir alles äh verlinken, so wie es hier guter Stil ist. Äh in den Netzpolitik Punkt DE.
Hast du sind wir durch mit dem Thema jetzt.
Ja, ich glaube, wir haben's.
Gut, dann gehen wir jetzt in den in entspannten äh äh Pilot über. Was wolltest du fragen?
Na, ich wollte nur fragen, ob man eigentlich dieses WWW noch dazu sagt für Domains, ich habe mir das letztens wieder angewohnt, nachdem ich's nie gemacht habe.
Ähm aber ich ich glaube, das hier ist nicht das Publikum, wo wir das noch dazunehmen muss, aber es es wird dann teilweise so gefragt, brauche ich da das WWW davor? Das sind noch Fragen, die die einem gestellt werden, wenn man so vor allem mit älteren Semestern spricht.
Ja, das ist eine gute Frage und ähm ich denke, das Ding ist eigentlich durch.
Weltweit Web hat sich abgelöst, oder?
Es es wäre, wäre sicherlich ganz angemessen noch die entsprechenden Ali, also einfach stumm äh einzubauen, um ganz sicher zu gehen, weil's ja dann auch, was weiß ich
immer noch so merkwürdige, automatische Complition-Mechanismen, die vielleicht irgendwo gefragt noch WWWs davor schreiben, weil kann ja sein, ne, da sollte man zumindest drauf achten, dass in dem Fall nicht eine ganz andere Webseite äh auf einmal
zu zum Tage kommt, weil man das halt einfach selber nicht mehr so testet.
Ja das das sind auf jeden Fall ist da wichtig.
Im Webverkehr. Gut, ich denke, da machen wir den Sack jetzt einfach mal zu, Thomas
Vielen, vielen Dank für äh die Ausführung und ähm ihr könnt euch ja auch mal hier Thomas äh Vorträge zu den zahlreichen Themen äh anschauen, haben wir auch äh verlinkt hier in den. Ja und.
Nächste Woche geht's dann auch wieder weiter mit Linus, denke ich. Und äh bedanke mich fürs Zuhören und sage tschüss und bis bald.
Ciao, ciao. Cool. So, ich komme auf eine Stunde dreizehn.